desesperación y caos mientras las
ambulancias llegaban a las calles de
pesahuair Pakistán tras un ataque bomba
en la mezquita de la ciudad que estaba
abarrotada de fieles con al menos 260
personas en la hora de la oración
llegamos al lugar tras la explosión y
estaba en pleno caos rescate a siete
personas y las metí en ambulancias de
las siete dos murieron y otras cinco
fueron trasladadas al hospital una parte
de la mezquita se había derrumbado
totalmente a causa de la explosión no
puedo dar la cifra exacta de víctimas
había muchos fieles en el momento de la
explosión
tras El Atentado La mezquita quedó
destrozada con decenas de muertos y lo
que más preocupa a las autoridades en
estos momentos son las personas que
están atrapadas entre los escombros
salvar al máximo número posible es la
prioridad del gobierno
nos estábamos preparando para la oración
y nos dirigimos a la mezquita estábamos
en las escaleras cuando se produjo la
explosión dentro de la
por el momento nadie ha reivindicado a
la autoría del crimen pero el Primer
Ministro pakistaní aseguró que fue un
atentado suicida ya que se produjo justo
en la hora de la oración cuando hay más
afluencia en el edificio y ya que pesada
en la frontera con Afganistán es
objetivo de grupos terroristas este
atentado es el peor de la ciudad desde
marzo del año pasado cuando otro
atentado suicida en la mezquita Chita
reivindicado por el estado islámico dejó
al menos 58 fallecidos